centrale pour brouyère 12 à la réunion
11 centrales le corps que nous
recherchons vient d'être retrouvé il se
trouve dans la zone des minerais rares
en bordure du ruisseau assez difficile
d'accès lancée le protocole judiciaire
ça fait trois ans que l'enquêté est au
point mort on n'a toujours pas de
coupable
si on en avait un mais il a été acquitté
ils nous envoient des gens de la pj
alors on va faire ce qu'il faut et se
mettre à leur disposition en vous ne
vous ferez sous les ordres du sergent
bevilacqua et du caporal jamhour
l'importance pour toute chose c'est de
savoir si vous avez envie de venir avec
toi je sais dire dans sa veste en jean
bienvenue à la commère on a trouvé du
sang dans la voiture de padilla qui
n'avait pas d'alibi et la relation
divine avec sa fille c'est donc le
mobile du meurtre vous ne pouviez pas me
juger deux fois pour le même crime
moi je pose des questions avec les
réponses qu on donne on fabrique une
histoire vous prédire est coupable ou
innocent et s'y retrouver l'assassin
n'était peut-être pas la meilleure chose
qu'on puisse faire pour elle pour
égorger quelqu'un il faut se rapprocher
de très près on va chercher là où les
autres on va chercher on l'a pas
retrouvée elle s'en ira pas tuer
quelqu'un de bien
vous sortez cet argent
je sais que tu sais d'où il y avait
d'autres faits
pourquoi avoir fait cette vidéo
tu te rends compte qu'on a répondu à
aucune des questions qu'on s'y déposent
au début ce n'était peut-être pas les
bonnes